let's take it to the streets so our
first real proper trailer for the
defenders has come out it's not a teaser
it's not a clip it this is a good proper
trailer for the thing and having been
someone who expressed fairly recently my
points of being nervous about the
defenders then I I had a lot riding on
this thing I needed this thing to
reassure me that the fears that I have
about this show aren't going to be
realized and that I was just being
paranoid because I didn't like I insist
as much as I disliked it so you know I I
needed this thing to reassure me and it
did I'm feeling much much better right
now not everything is perfect I'll just
get this out of laid an ear and it's
still kind of insufferable but I'm
getting a sense of his balance with the
other characters which is that they kind
of look at him like your dick and he is
a dick and you know I like that he blue
K just kind of takes the punches and
he's like what are you doing and you
know that Claire will yell at him like
or bad both of them I suppose but I like
that he seems to be rubbing these other
characters the wrong way the same way he
rubbed me the wrong way I would like to
think that the makers of the show will
use that as an opportunity to grow Danny
and the character so that when he comes
back in other shows whether his own show
gets another season or he shows up in
Luke Cage or whatever that he will be in
a better place as a character than he
was in his own show that might be hoping
too much because this probably is more
you know a bit like The Avengers it's
more about the team up and the enjoyment
of seeing them together and you don't do
your big you know character changing
things so much in that but you know
maybe maybe they'll take advantage of
that we'll see but even though Danny
still kind of sucks in the way he
appears to be playing off everybody else
I think you've got to make it much more
palpable for Mia so that is a very good
thing the other thing that I had
concerns about was the
because as you know the hand the hand as
they have shown up in the show so far
hasn't really worked for me they work
kind of in the first season of daredevil
insofar as that one ninja fight that he
had one-on-one with that guy was awesome
but the hand as an organization it's
just gotten weaker and weaker and weaker
the more we found out about them so I've
been concerned about the villains but
I'm not now not because I'm something
reassured about the hand I'm not now
because I saw Sigourney Weaver now I
love Sigourney Weaver anyway she's one
of my favorite actresses seriously ever
but just to see her presence and the
sense of commanding and danger that she
just exudes standing there just standing
on the screen just look at her go oh
crap and that is that is what I need she
exudes the same kind of power that
Vincent D'Onofrio did as the kingpin
yeah he gets that I mean I expect a very
different character but I get that same
sense of an eight power offer that is
what I need and so that was very
reassuring on that front as far as the
rest of it goes oh you know what the
other thing was I was a little bit
concerned about the action because the
action in Iron Fist booth terrible but
we got some clips you know a bit a
hallway fight that was much more
reminiscent of Daredevils action than it
was about Fitz action so I saw that I'm
like oh the action looks good
danny is going to be is going to be
tempered by these other characters
Sigourney Weaver is just exuding menace
huh I feel so much better now I'd be
almost completely relieved does this
mean is now going to be perfect although
these could still go wrong but my nerves
and the things that I was worried about
are we're almost all addressed by this
trailer I really like it and I like kind
of I like that Jessica Jones is just
being the smartass the snarky smartass
of the group and that Luke Cage if
anyone's going to bring a sense of
levity seems like it's got to be him he
is probably the right ones
that we've got stick back and I always
like Scott Glenn I the character use up
to this when it's been a little I'm not
going to sure what to make of it but I
like him as a friend ins as an actor I
always like having around it's such a
great voice so all of that is working
for me dude we're hitting that we're
getting electro back which um I got is
good I'm not gonna say mixed feelings
about but I'm not necessarily pumped for
that because I wasn't in love with her
and their CC something she was bad she
wasn't horrible but she definitely
wasn't behind light if you didn't leave
all that much of an impression on me so
you know maybe we'll get more from her
I'll be interested to see if they seem
to bring her story to some sort of a
natural closing this or if that's just
going to lead into daredevil season
three well I mean lots of little things
we saw misty night misty back love misty
the whole vibe of the thing it just it
had a nice energy it's nice seeing the
way you know the little glimpses we get
of how these characters are interacting
the chemistry seems to be pretty good
between them that's going to be that
that's a big part of what makes the team
ups work or fail how do these characters
work together and the little glimpses we
get so far looking pretty good so yeah
I'm feeling much better about this
series on the bag and on the virtues of
this trailer so Netflix Marvel well done
seriously good job so those are my
thoughts on the defenders trailer have
you seen it what were your thoughts on
it whatever they were drop something out
in the comments let's talk about it
don't forget to Like subscribe check me
out on Twitter at council of geeks give
a listen to the council of geeks pocket
and b punch like a girl podcast both
available on separate feeds on itunes
and stitcher and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]